hallo mein name ist khan herzlich
willkommen wir heute zu einem neuen
video wir vielleicht auch einige meiner
instagram bilder gesehen habe bin ich
gerade im urlaub und da haben mich sehr
viele leute gefragt wieso ein typischer
tag in meinem urlaub aussieht deswegen
habe ich mir gedacht ich nehme euch
einfach mal einen kompletten tag lang
mit zwar nicht besonders fetten kamera
weil ich nicht zum großen bizeps ab und
sonne fette kamera die ganze zeit zu
hause sondern einfach mit meinem iphone
also ich hab einfach mit meinem handy so
gefilmt als ich aufgestanden bin und was
wir dann schritt für schritt den tag
über gemacht haben im ist verstehen dass
das jetzt kein komplett normaler tag ist
also machen jeden tag irgendwas anderes
aber das halt so ein tag der am
ähnlichsten dem tram kommt der meisten
erleben wie sie das jetzt einfach mal
hintereinander eingeblendet sorry falls
die audio und videoqualität und
tonqualität und alle anderen qualitäten
dies gibt sorry falls das jetzt nicht so
krass ist wir das sonst von mir oder
anderen youtuber gewohnt seinem handy
aufgenommen aber ich dachte einfach idee
ist cool ein tag in meinem urlaub zu
zeigen aber ich fange jetzt mal an 30
ich stehe jetzt auf zwei flüge aber
jetzt erstmal duschen ja vielleicht
endlich in voller drecksack und
natürlich dusche
wir fahren jetzt erst mal frühstücken
männer schön
wirklich sehr schön meer strand auch
sehr schön
wir prüfen wir jetzt
guten appetit an uns wir sind freilich
mit essen
ich bin richtig voll hier sind jetzt
fertig mit frühstück und machen jetzt
eine pokémon tour
ich sitze auf dem klo
es ist wunderbar das wetter uns badehose
angezogen strand fertig gemacht und
gehen jetzt am strand
es ist wahr das ist sehr sehr warm
wir gehen jetzt allesamt ins meer
duschen und ab er muss gerade alles klar
ich bin doch nicht duschen sondern wir
sind es
ich habe einen leichten sonnenbrand und
meine augen sind extrem rollt welchem
salzwasser war wir uns gerade papier
geholt haben eigentlich besser bestellt
diese freiheit bekommen die sei da noch
immer nicht da aber die werden wir
gleich am strand essen
jetzt kurz zu hause weil wir noch was
weg bringen mussten aber jetzt schauen
wir uns hier quasi als abschluss des
tages den sonnenuntergang
wir haben uns jetzt gerade den
sonnenuntergang am wasser angesehen da
echt geil aus das war jetzt war sich so
das ende von dem tag also die sonne
untergegangen aber wir gehen jetzt
glaube ich noch einen kollegen fifa
stock mal so denkt wahrscheinlich okay
dass gerade gesagt die genfer spielen
waren wir auch allerdings nur für zwei
drei partien danach so richtig müde war
sieht jetzt zurück nach hause gefahren
ich bin richtig finde ich jetzt quasi im
bett es ist gerade mal 11 uhr
normalerweise gehen wir jetzt auf ihn
wohin und so ein bisschen feiern mit
freunden und so aber heute ist irgendwie
total fertig wir schon gemerkt habe war
mir fast von 11 bis 18 uhr nur am strand
und haben volleyball gespielt über allem
mehr und ich hab den bis zu sonnenbrand
und sieht man das eigentlich okay man
sie überhaupt nicht wie man auf jeden
fall bibel ko
das war jetzt der letzte tag in meinen
ferien deswegen habe ich es gerade noch
meine sachen fertig gepackt da steht
mein koffer und da dies eine tragetasche
wir müssen halt morgen
7 uhr aufstehen weil um 39 die fähre
fährt und nicht dementsprechend ist
irgendwie um 15 uhr wieder in köln bin
deswegen muss ich jetzt schlafen dass
ihr bildet jetzt quasi das ende meines
tages
ich hoffe euch hat das wir gefallen als
gabe luca machte sogar noch eine and
also ich verabschiede mich erst mal an
dieser stelle
ja und das war jetzt quasi ein
kompletter normaler tag in meinem urlaub
übrigens toll dass ich so gut bin aber
ich habe übelste sonnenbrand heute an
den tag bekommt das video heute war
jetzt ein bisschen anders weil ich nur
mit dieser großen kamera den anfang und
das ende jetzt gemacht haben alle
zwischendrin irgendwie mit meinem handy
gefilmt habe ich hoffe einfach dass es
euch trotzdem irgendwie gefallen wenn es
uns getan hat würde ich mich über eine
bewertung freuen und schreibt mir die
kommentare ob normale tage bräuchen
urlaub auch so aussehen oder ob ihr her
nur zuhause chillen oder ob ihr die welt
rettet oder so umsonst sehen wir uns im
nächsten video wieder oder morgen und
übermorgen auf den video days also ich
werde keine autogrammstunde geben möchte
es lächerlich finde weil ich mich nicht
als probieren sehr aber ich laufe da so
ein bisschen rum